A new type of war has emerged, information
warfare.
This activity by the Russians is gonna go
down in history
as the greatest covert action campaign in
the history of Mother Russia.
So-called fake news can have real world consequences
it's a danger that must be addressed.
And you have to be the ones to do something
about it
or we will.
Last October, both houses of Congress
grilled the attorneys for the tech giants
Facebook, Twitter and Google
about Russian meddling and so-called fake
news.
You have been identified as the major distributors
of fake news.
We are not gonna go away, gentlemen.
Minnesota Senator Amy Klobuchar has already
introduced a piece of legislation
aimed at more tightly regulating online political
advertising.
The Honest Ads Act
would bring transparency and accountability
to paid political advertising.
But that only addresses a small portion of
the problem.
A Russian troll farm called the Internet Research
Agency
produced thousands of unpaid posts using fake
accounts and Facebook groups
that targeted hot button issues like race
and immigration.
Their strategy is to take a crack in our society
and turn it into a chasm.
And it's not just foreign misinformation,
some lawmakers want better policing of sites
like Info Wars,
the Austin Texas based conspiracy site run
by Alex Jones.
A short time ago on Twitter,
if you clicked on the hashtag #NYCTerroristAttack,
the top tweet links to an Info Wars story
with the headline:
'Imam: I warned De Blasio About NYC Terror;
He Was Too Busy Bashing Trump.'
Do you have a responsibility to flag something
as this was fake news?
We see our users do that a lot, we are an open public
platform with-
You must feel like you have some responsibility.
We are deeply concerned about that and figuring
out ways we can do it with the right balance.
While Democrats seemed concerned
that tech companies don't do enough to police
content on their platforms,
Republicans and Conservatives have expressed
concern
that they do too much to cultivate their users'
news feeds.
Your power sometimes scares me.
Do you consider your sites to be a neutral
public forum?
Google should be regulated like the public
utility it is
to make sure it doesn't further distort the
free flow of information.
With both sides increasingly suspicious of
big tech
the regulation of online speech seems imminent.
The specter of fake news and foreign propaganda
posing as factual reporting
is a complicated problem that many lawmakers
seem eager to tackle.
But as President Trump demonstrates on a near
daily basis:
what constitutes fake news is often in the
eye of the beholder.
You are fake news, go ahead.
This isn't to deny the existence or importance
of things like facts
but to say that handing the authority to determine
truth over to government officials
could be disastrous.
It's important to remember that being on Facebook
or Twitter or YouTube
is still a voluntary activity.
Because customers can always log off,
these companies already have strong incentives
to keep their platforms relatively free of
bots and trolls
and to improve the user experience through
actively curating content.
What we're trying to do actually is provide
each user a personalized news feed
that will be the content that's most interesting
to that user.
Treating social media as some sort of public
utility is quite simply a power grab
that all but guarantees politicians and un-elected
bureaucrats
will decide what information should appear
in Americans' news feeds
and would likely grant the government even
greater access to our private communications
than it already has.
Are you intending to turn over to the committee
any kind of direct messaging that went on
among the different accounts.
Direct messages are the private communication
between our users
and so we take that privacy right and responsibility
very seriously.
We don't want to put ourselves in the position
of being the arbiter of truth
we don't think that's a tenable position for
any company or industry.
It's probably true that Facebook, Twitter
and Google
aren't in a great position to be the arbiters of truth.
But the government is in an even worse position.
This isn't the first time governments have
tried to control new tools of mass communication.
Much like the internet, the advent of the
printing press provoked panic and backlash
among the elite institutions it disrupted.
America's first public newspaper was shut
down after a single edition
because it spread rumors about the sex lives
of government officials
and published what the colonial government
described as 'uncertain reports.'
or what we might call 'fake news.'
And for the crime of publishing without a
license
the government imprisoned and later ran out
of town another early colonial newspaper editor,
James Franklin, older brother to Benjamin
Franklin, who went on to run that paper.
A few decades earlier, John Milton famously
criticized
the British government's regulation of materials
produced by the printing press,
Writing in 1644
that 'Truth and Understanding are not such wares
as to be monopolized and traded in by tickets and statute-'
Instead, better to 'Let Truth and Falsehood
grapple.'
Why was this false content allowed to remain
in place?
There was a small amount of tweets relative
to the size of the platform
but impressions of tweets calling out those
things as fake were 8 times as large.
Granting government even the slightest control
over the free flow of information on the internet
under the guise of fighting falsehoods
will ironically make more difficult the task
of discovering truth.
Some level of fake news, misinformation and
trolling
might just be the price we have to pay for
free and open discussion.